yeah the last time the last time for
those that didn't hear the podcast we
had stevo on we should play that again
during this podcast so they could hear
it yeah we couldn't repeat that yeah
my family thought it was hilarious i
didn't but you cried didn't you cry yeah
i almost cried
you said you did cry i was about to well
let's listen to the call let's see if
you cry you can tell me what you're
thinking during the year there it is
right there oh no it should be where's
no no
that's okay he didn't cut directly we'll
cut it in we could cut it in
but i'd love to talk about
what it is
and apparently just to preface this he
said he was going to call you
this is your uh uh first big movie yeah
yeah this means a lot to you yes and uh
like uh johnny said the the uh the
studio is really involved in what you're
allowed to talk about when you're
allowed to talk about so he decided we
do prank calls here all the time so
which i guess you'll know that now yeah
i know now so this is stevo calling you
sure let's do a prank
all right so do you know
did you discuss with our producers what
the prank would be like what you're
thinking i i didn't i i did receive word
that that you like doing pranks and
would like to do something like that on
the air so what they're saying uh my
producers here are saying here's another
idea you want to call zach holmes
and okay my homeboy zach yeah who's new
he's the newest member of the jackass
crew isn't he i didn't say that
knoxville said it a week ago oh daddy uh
okay undercover why are you not allowed
to talk about it i was under the
impression that we weren't supposed to
uh
to talk about that too much but i didn't
say it pause for a second
and you could fast forward in silence to
when the it stops to when he starts to
get him on the phone but the the thing
is that they have been pretty hard on
you guys as far as not hard but i think
that this is an amazing promotion
machine that goes into this and the
studio they didn't even it took a while
for him to announce that there were even
new cast members right yeah right and
were you told not to speak about it i i
didn't say anything were you told not to
yeah yeah specifically when we signed
contracts and stuff like we're not yeah
yeah we're not supposed to talk about it
at all so people didn't even know where
you were going to work no yeah i didn't
i didn't tell anyone
wow yeah so this is what he had told us
but apparently what you weren't aware of
is johnny had announced your names
on a show a week before but you didn't
know that steve knew you didn't know
that so he decided to call you because
this is the big break this is a break of
a lifetime and this is steve calling you
zack
call
i don't set up my voicemail either
everyone's talking about you're in the
movie i'm getting asked about it like in
interviews
oh yeah
i know dude like uh and it's it's it's
kind of [ __ ] dude
like uh
i don't like i i don't think knoxville
was allowed to say that dude
and now no why don't i talk to them
you talked to who
no no not when knoxville said that in
the thing
we're allowed to say that we're in the
movie
and that we're uh that's not what i'm
hearing dude i'm hearing that like that
it's a big [ __ ] problem dude
and they're like what do you mean shawna
said that we're allowed to say that
we're in the movie and they were
ah dude she had it wrong dude
it's kind of [ __ ]
like no way dude are you serious
yeah she literally told me we're allowed
to say we're allowed those paramounts
that we're allowed to say we're in the
movies i mean maybe maybe things got
tangled up but the word is now that like
they can't even
you know
when he who sings to you
i mean dude i'm
sorry i'm talking dad to everybody and
then gary and paramount
[Music]
i
know i think you're going to lose your
footage dude
what
[Laughter]
you're crying
oh my god
i mean dude i i think they got to cut
you out dude dude shut the [ __ ] up
dude i was about to [ __ ] cry dude
i can't okay all right turn it off
but you were about to cry i love how
easy and how sensitive you are as a
human being i mean you're just a good
guy and you've got a heart you take it
and you cry but if somebody says hey
come over i want to duct tape your nuts
and i'd love you to jump in the cacti
you got no problem with that yeah pretty
much wow
you are a great guy though and you are a
good friend and you i love that you're
sensitive and and he is a good have you
guys become close yeah we've we've
bonded pretty closely over no don't say
that to him
the last time
did you hear this story that i was
telling what happened you'll end up with
his lips on your nipples oh you know um
i've had worse things on my nipples
i'm sure worse lips yeah um what's the
worst thing you've had on your nipple
probably an ex-boyfriend yeah
you know
but uh but yeah i mean i i we got we got
close
pretty quickly and and i love zach like
i'm so glad that
for our friendship
oh
now you're going to make them cry tell
me how glad you are for our friendships
yeah you're not saying anything about
you i am very happy that we're friends
[Music]
you